W
CLEARLY MEANT TO SAY RIGHT TO
LIFE, AND CALLS IT A MISHAP.
THERE'S A NEWS POLL OUT TODAY
IS SHOWING THAT NEARLY SIX AND
TEN PEOPLE DISAPPROVE OF THE
DECISION TO OVERTURN ROE V.
WADE, AND THAT INCLUDES TWO
THIRDS OF WOMEN SURVEYED.
JOINING ME NOW IS REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN WARREN DAVIDSON OF
OHIO.
GOOD EVENING TO YOU,
CONGRESSMAN.
>> GOOD EVENING, PATTA.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT OHIO.
YOUR STATES HEARTBEAT BILL,
WHICH IS NOW IN EFFECT, IT BANS
ABORTIONS ONCE A FETAL
HEARTBEAT IS DETECTIVE, ROUGHLY
SIX WEEKS INTO A PREGNANCY.
THAT IS A TIME WHEN SOME PEOPLE
MIGHT NOT EVEN KNOW THEY'RE
PREGNANT.
THERE IS NO EXCEPTION FOR RAPE
OR INCEST.
SO MY QUESTION IS, WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN A 12-YEAR-OLD GIRL FALLS
PREGNANT AFTER BEING RAPED?
ARE YOU OKAY WITH HER BEING
FORCED TO CARRY THAT FETUS TO
TERM?
>> WHILE, UNDER OHIO'S LAW, YOU
KNOW, IT DOESN'T BAN THINGS
LIKE A ABORTIONS.
SO LET'S SAY SOMEONE WAS RAPED,
YOU DON'T KNOW YOU ARE RAPED
FOR TWO MONTHS?
I THINK THAT IT'S INCORPORATED
IN TO DEAL WITH THAT.
THAT IS A COMPROMISE.
PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT LIFE BEGINS
AT CONCEPTION, THAT'S WITH THE
SCIENCE SAYS.
--
>> WELL, THE SCIENCE IS NOT
CONCLUSIVE ON THAT.
THERE IS NO CONSENSUS ON LIFE
BEGINNING AT CONCEPTION.
BUT I KNOW THAT THAT IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT YOU
BELIEVE, AND OTHER
CONSERVATIVES BELIEVE.
BUT I JUST WANT TO ASK YOU
AGAIN, BECAUSE THIS OBVIOUSLY
RAISES SOME TOUGH QUESTIONS.
OF COURSE, RIGHT?
WHAT HAPPENS OF A 12-YEAR-OLD
GETS RAPED?
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH HER
HAVING TO NOW CARRY THAT BABY
TO TERM BECAUSE THERE IS NO
EXCEPTION FOR HER CASE?
UNDER OHIO LAW?
>> I FULLY SUPPORT OHIO'S LAW
AND I COMMEND OUR, FRANKLY, OUR
GOVERNOR AND OUR LEGISLATURE
FOR PASSING IT, WERE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS HAD FAILED.
THEY PASSED IT, IT WAS HELD UP
BY THE COURTS, AND RELIEF FROM
THE INJUNCTION WAS FILED
IMMEDIATELY ON FRIDAY.
IT IS NOW THE LAW IN OHIO.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT LAW, AND
IT IS A COMPROMISE.
AND LIKE I SAID, RAPE IS RAISED
AS AN OBJECTION, BUT THE
HEARTBEAT BILL ALREADY DEALS
WITH THAT.
IT'S HARD TO CONCEIVE OF
SOMEBODY WHO DOESN'T KNOW THEY
WERE RAPED FOR TWO MONTHS.
>> LOOK, I'M NOT GONNA PUT
MYSELF IN THE SHOES OF SOMEONE
WHO IS RAPED, BUT I'M SURE IF
THEY WERE HERE TO SPEAK WITH
YOU, THEY WOULD BE PUSHING BACK
ON THAT NOTION, BUT THERE'S ALL
KINDS OF TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES
THAT WOULD HAPPEN AFTER SUCH A
THING, AND IN THE PROCESSING OF
IT, AND THEN FINDING OUT YOUR
PREGNANT, AND SO FORTH.
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPLEXITIES.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT OHIO
WHEN IT COMES TO ITS RANKINGS
IN TERMS OF INFANT MORTALITY.
IT'S NEAR THE MIDDLE FOR
MATERNAL MORTALITY, IT'S RANKED
41ST IN INFANT MORTALITY.
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED,
AND WITH THIS BAN IN PLACE,
THAT RATE OF INFANT MORTALITY
WILL LIKELY GO UP.
SO, WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO TO
COMBAT THAT AND PROTECT THESE
DISADVANTAGED WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WHO ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THIS ABORTION BAN?
>> LOOK, OHIO, UNFORTUNATELY,
WE HAVE OVER HALF OF THE LIVE
BIRTHS AND OHIO ARE ON
MEDICAID.
SO WE HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
AMOUNT OF OUR FAMILIES THAT ARE
GROWING OUR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
I THINK THAT OVERWHELMINGLY
ACCOUNTS FOR THE LOSS OF LIFE
IN LABOR AND DELIVERY.
SO I THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT,
HOW DO WE STRENGTHEN THAT,
EARLY TREATMENT OF ANYTHING
THAT GOES WRONG IN THE
PREGNANCY IS ALWAYS IMPORTANT.
I THINK CONSISTENT PRENATAL
CARE THROUGH THAT PROCESS --
YOU, KNOW MY WIFE AND I HAD OUR
KIDS WHEN WE WERE IN THE ARMY,
AND THAT WAS GOVERNMENT
OPERATED HEALTH CARE.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THE FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS WOULD AT LEAST
MEET THAT STANDARD, AND WHERE
THEY FALL SHORT, OUR OFFICE IS
OPEN FOR CASEWORK TO TRY TO
SUPPORT IT.
WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY.
>> I KNOW THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT GETS A LOT OF PEOPLE
WORKED UP, BUT I THINK WET --
THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN RIGHT
NOW THAT SO MANY STATES,
INCLUDING OHIO, HAVE THESE
ABORTION BANS.
AND THERE'S BEEN THIS FIGHT FOR
A BABY IN THE WOMB, BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE FIGHT FOR THE CHILD
AFTER IT LEAVES THE WIN?
THE DISADVANTAGED MOTHER?
ARE YOU GONNA COMMIT TO
FIGHTING FOR THEM?
>> I ALREADY DO FIGHT FOR THEM,
AND FRANKLY, LOOK, AS SOMEBODY
WHO BELIEVES THAT LIFE BEGINS
AT CONCEPTION, WE WANT EVERY
BABY TO BE A HEALTHY BABY, AND
WE KNOW THAT SOME BABIES ARE
CHALLENGED FROM BIRTH.
I WAS AT CHURCH THIS MORNING
WITH SOMEONE WHO IS PROVIDING
FOSTER CARE FOR A PRENATAL --
HAS BABIES OUT JUST NOW AT FULL
TERM, AND HAS SPENT THE FIRST
NEARLY TWO MONTHS IN NICK YOU
TO TRY TO GET STABLE.
>> THERE'S ALL KINDS OF STORIES
HERE, THE BOTTOM LINE IS HE SAY
YOU'RE FIGHTING, BUT THERE ARE
60,000 KIDS IN OHIO THAT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN AWAY --
I THINK IT'S 9000 IN FOSTER
CARE.
THERE'S CONCERN THAT THAT
SYSTEM IS GONNA BE OVERLOADED,
AND WHAT'S GONNA BE DONE TO
HELP THEM WITH RESOURCES?
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE, HE
IS CALLING FOR A NATIONAL
ABORTION BAN, HOUSE LEADERS ARE
CALLING FOR A NATIONAL BAN
AFTER 15 WEEKS --
DO YOU SUPPORT A NATIONAL,
NATIONWIDE BAN?
>> I BELIEVE LIFE BEGINS AT
CONCEPTION, AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
PASSIONATELY DISAGREE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE DEMOCRATS
WERE ON THIS ISSUE, WHY WAS
THIS CASE BEFORE THE SUPREME
COURT?
THEY WERE UNWILLING FOR
MISSISSIPPI TO LIMIT ABORTION
TO 15 WEEKS.
NOT ONLY THAT, HOUSE DEMOCRATS
PUT ON THE FLOOR THAT OPPOSED
EVERY SINGLE MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE DEMOCRATIC CONFERENCE --
OPPOSED THE PROTECTION ACT.
THESE BABIES HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DELIVERED.
THEY STILL WON ONE OF PROTECT
THAT LIFE.
THEY SUPPORTED GOVERNOR NOR
TERMS DECISION THAT --
THAT'S NOT ABORTION, THAT'S
INFANTICIDE.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, DO YOU
SUPPORT A NATIONWIDE BAN ON
ABORTION?
>> I SUPPORT LIFE AT CONCEPTION
ACT IN THE HOUSE.
I'M A COSPONSOR.
AND OHIO, I THINK OHIO'S OUR --
HEARTBEAT BILL IS A REASONABLE
POSITION OF COMPROMISE, AND I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE STATES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY GET THEIR, NOT BY
FORCE, JUST BY MORAL CONSENSUS,
THAT THIS IS A LIFE AND IT IS
PRECIOUS.
IT SHOULD BE PROTECTED.
AND IF A MOTHER SAYS, YOU KNOW,
I DON'T THINK I CAN RAISE THIS
BABY, THERE ARE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO WOULD LOVE TO
ADOPT THAT BABY.
AND HOPEFULLY, WE CAN MAKE
ADOPTION AND FOSTER CARE A MORE
VIABLE OPTION FOR EVERYONE --
>> UNFORTUNATELY, THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM IS SO INCREDIBLY
BROKEN, THOUGH.
WE'VE DONE STORY AFTER STORY ON
THAT.
BUT WHEN IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
SAYING IS, YOU WOULD LIKE OTHER
STATES TO ADOPT A BILL LIKE
OHIO HAS, BUT YOU ARE NOT FOR A
FEDERAL LAW MANDATING EVERY
STATE HAVE ABORTION.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BEFORE
WE MOVE ON, BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
OTHER TOPICS WE NEED TO GET TO.
>> I HAVE A COSPONSOR IN THE
LIFE IN CONCEPTION ACTS AND
CONS --
IF YOU WANT TO PUSH ABORTION
FROM CONCEPTION TO DELIVERY ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE, WE'RE
GONNA PUSH BACK WITH WHAT WE
TRULY DO BELIEVE IS LIFE AT
CONCEPTION.
I THINK THE COURTS DELIVERED A
POSITION THAT SAYS, IT'S OKAY
IF STATES ARE DIFFERENT.
THEY COULD'VE GONE TO THE FULL
EXTREME POSITION UNDER THE 14TH
AMENDMENT, THAT PEOPLE WOULD
VIEW IS RADICAL, BUT NO ONE
CO